showboating is a no-no in pool
it can actually get you killed if you go
to the wrong place hey gq
i'm tony robles i'm a professional pool
player and this
is the breakdown
[Music]
first up the hustler did that ever
happen to you
all of a sudden you feel like you can't
miss
a hustler in pooh is a player that
pretends
that he or she cannot play in the hopes
of getting a high-stakes game
it is very rare that you'll see hustling
nowadays it used to be a pretty big
thing back in the days but the pusing
has changed
so much to the point when you walk in a
pool hall you see
families playing pool one wall corner
pocket
some players can spot hustlers very
easily
and some cannot i know this one player
and he would practice
aiming where he would stroke the cue
stick back and forth
he would go to the side kind of like a
crooked stroke
and he would do it intentionally so
people thought he couldn't play he used
to drive people nuts
but he would win most of the time that's
how it was to hustle a lot of people
[Music]
when people played back in the days
whether it was in a pool hall
even a community center that had a table
people would gamble all the time
it was actually very common especially
after the movie the hustle came out
because everyone wanted to be a hustler
the word pool came from betting parlors
on horse races and where they used to
put a pool of money together to bet on
races and eventually
they wonder putting pool tables there in
order to keep
people busy in between races i dreamed
about this game
fat man i dreamed about this game every
night on the road
the people that you see on the side
right there each and every one of them
most likely has a bet they have a stake
in the match and a lot of times it gets
crazy i've been in gambling matches
where you would see one guy says
i'll bet you 25 that your friend loses
this rack
well i'll bet you a thousand dollars
that he loses iraq
so a lot of times the best change
depending on who's there
if they see someone that has a lot of
money is winning the bet they'll go all
out
and take the risk of either you know
losing a lot or winning a lot
most of the time when players gamble in
a bar
the owners don't know about it there are
places that forbid it but there
really aren't too many but most matches
actually take place
in a pool hall two ball side parks
in the game of pool there are various
games that require you to call a shot or
call the pocket that you intend to
pocket the ball in
for example straight pool which is also
known as 14.1 continuous is a game
where every shot must be called if
you're playing in a tournament
and someone pockets a ball that's right
in front of the pocket but they failed
to call the shot
it's really not considered a miss or a
penalty only because it was obvious that
they were shooting it into that pocket
whereas if you have a shot that you have
the option to shoot it in the side
pocket or corner pocket it's recommended
that you call it in order to avoid
problems because someone could come out
of nowhere and say well you didn't call
the shot and you lose your turn
a lot of people confuse pool with
billiards
billiards is a game that's played on a
pool table
with no pockets and it's a completely
different game whereas in the game of
pool
you have a table that has six pockets
and the object is to sink as many balls
into the pocket as possible
very good shot that is actually an
illegal shot
he actually shoots a cue ball and
strikes the object aboard an angle to
get both of them out of the way
so that his cue stick will then hit the
other object ball in front of the cue
ball to pocket the ball in the cue ball
is what we call the white ball it's the
only ball that's
allowed to be struck with your cue stick
during a pool game
you're technically only supposed to
strike the cue ball when you're shooting
a shot and pull
not striking an object ball that is a
foul and it's a loss of turn
now you don't leave much when you mess
through your batman i highly recommend
chalking the cue stick before each and
every single shot
the chalk is needed to create the
friction that's necessary in order to
strike the cue ball correctly because if
you fail to chalk up then the tip starts
to slide
off the cue ball itself and that's what
we call a misq
and you will lose the ability to strike
the ball exactly the way you want it to
paul newman actually studied the game a
bit for this movie he's hitting every
single shot very hard and in addition to
that anyone that plays
real pool knows that you're supposed to
have a pre-shot routine
that's the steps that are necessary in
order to execute a shot if you notice in
that scene he's already down on the shot
and waiting for the cue ball to stop
which means he hasn't lined up his body
with the shot
so there's a good chance that he
probably missed that shot you want to
make sure
assuming the shot is that way that your
body is lined up in a perfectly straight
line with a shot so what you want to do
is you want to make sure
your right foot is underneath the cue
stick that keeps everything else in line
as far as
the head the shoulder the elbow and the
wrist so that way you can go in a dead
straight line as you're following
through once you've struck the ball
[Music]
the shot that paul newman shot here i
don't believe
he actually shot that shot because it's
an extremely difficult shot that's
called the massey shot
where you strike with at a 90 degree
angle with the cue stick
and by going at a downward angle it's
almost like putting backspin
and you're sending the cue ball forward
but since you're applying so much
backspin at an extreme angle the cubo
wants to come back towards you so it's
like a curved shot
so final thoughts on the hustler i would
definitely say that it's legit paul
newman shot most of the shots
except for the massey shot that's
probably why they didn't show him
shooting the shot in addition to that
jackie gleason was also known as a great
pool player he was a 50 ball
consistent runner in straight pull he
had the ability to run
or pocket 50 consecutive balls before a
miss
next up the color of money what you got
in there
[Music]
the reason why most of them are two
pieces because it makes it easier to
transport
it is normal for players to have their
own cue when they go to a pool room
because once you get too
used to a specific weight and a feel
and a millimeter of the shaft that if
you were to grab another q it actually
feels alien
there was a very famous custom queue
maker by the name of george balabushka
and he has always been considered to
make the greatest
pool cues what tom cruise has in this
scene is a balabushka q
i've seen some battle bushka queues sell
for as much as 80 thousand dollars
this movie is pretty much a continuation
of the hustler the difference is that
when paul newman played with jackie
gleason the game of choice back then was
straightforward when tom cruise took on
the role
the popular game then and still is
the game of nine ball wrapped in a
diamond shape and the balls are shot in
america water from one through nine
this is something that drives pool
players crazy after he pocketed the four
ball
he has a slightly awkward angle on from
the cue ball to the five boy it's more
like a 45 degree angle away from the
pocket so he has to
obviously strike the five ball on the
right side in order to send it towards
the pocket
when he actually shoots a shot they set
it up so that it's a dead straight shot
he doesn't have to cut the ball at all
and by
cutting i mean he doesn't have to go to
the side of the ball he hits the ball
dead square
showboating is a no-no in pool it can
actually get you killed if you go to the
wrong place
i knew of this legendary player he once
won a gambling match for a lot of money
and jumped on top of the pool table and
started dancing
and his opponent got so upset that he
took out a shotgun
and his friend who was there with him
actually saved his life and taught the
guy out of not shooting him so
showboating is usually not good because
if you're in a tournament you lose
fans but if you're in a gambling match
you could potentially lose your life
never seen it happen where a player
would show off and
decide to shoot the last or the winning
ball with one hand you can end up
damaging your reputation because you're
trying to insult the guy and make him
look really bad
it's good to do it if you're playing
with friends but not when you're in a
serious
match you're basically letting your
opponent know that they're nothing
in front of a bunch of people and
insulting their game saying that you're
that much more better than they are
now tom cruise really practiced for this
film he did a tremendous job developing
a nice straight stroke his fundamentals
are intact you can see it he shot that
ball with
such authority this movie definitely
made poo cool
they started opening up a lot of upscale
rooms after the colored money came up
so that people can actually go in there
and have a good experience as opposed to
going to a smoke-filled room where you
got
seedy people it created a completely
different atmosphere it's been thriving
since then
[Music]
now that right there is what we call a
stop shot
if you strike the cue ball high it gives
it what we call
instant forward momentum so the cue ball
continues to roll forward
after contact if you strike the cue ball
low
it gives it back spin so that after
contact the cue ball comes back towards
you
but if you hit it anywhere by the
equator or slightly below
it creates a slide effect so the cue
ball actually
slides across the cloth as it reaches
the object it has no rotation it's not
going forward or backwards it has no
choice but to come to a complete stop
okay let's fast forward to later in the
movie
braking is when you strike the cue ball
as hard as
possible to spread the balls as much as
you can and
hopefully pocket a ball during the break
if you pocket a ball you continue your
inning
at the pro level if you fail to pocket a
ball on the break your opponent is going
to clear the table it's like any other
shot and pull you have to practice it a
lot in order to master it
as far as the setup is concerned for the
tournament the actual layout of the
tables
i thought they did a fantastic job
because that's what it looks like for
most pro tournaments they
keep a certain distance between tables
to make sure the players don't get
in each other's way when they're trying
to shoot anytime you go to a
professional pool tournament you will
see a four and a half by nine table
if you go to a bar most of the time it's
three and a half by seven
because it makes it easier for them to
put more than one the way the scoring
system works it all depends on the game
that you're playing
if you're playing let's say a ball or
nine ball they play what we call a race
so if let's say we play a race to seven
the first player to win seven games wins
a match
and in most pool halls you go to they
have a scoring system they have what
they call beads that are above the table
where you can slide them over every time
you win a rack
[Music]
the more you elevate the cue stick the
more you curve the ball because if you
were to shoot with a level q
the cube was just going to go in a dead
straight line it has no chance virtually
of
curving at all the fact that the cue
ball stopped right before
it fell was actually kind of lucky
it made it seem so awesome because had
the cue ball scratch he would have lost
his turn at the table and then the
incoming player would have had the
opportunity to win that rack
the level difficulty of this just to
make the shot is very
very tough but it's even tougher to
avoid a scratch
a scratch is when the cue ball is
pocketed and is considered a foul
so once you commit a file you lose your
turn at the table and depending where
you're playing at the incoming player
either gets
to take the cue ball in their hand
that's what we call ball in hand and
place it anywhere on the table or if you
play by the traditional rules
the incoming player gets ball in hand
behind the line
they do have special racks that are
diamond shaped
i recommend using a triangle wrap
because that gives you the ability to
have room to squeeze the balls together
and give yourself a tight rack because
it increases
the potential of pocketing balls on the
brake the proper way to rack a nine ball
is put the one ball as a head ball and
the nine ball in the middle
if you put the nine ball in the middle
it decreases the chances of pocketing
the nine ball in the corner pocket
so if you were to place a nine ball
anywhere other than the center of the
rack which is the third row
you might actually either lose the rack
or they will qualify all of you and then
your po
it's your opponent's turn to shoot
afterwards
in nine ball you must strike the lowest
ball first which is the one ball so the
one literally
stopped right in front of the nine so
his opponent when he saw that he got
disgusted and he just gave him the game
because he know that there's no way
a player is ever going to miss a shot
that's easy and in some tournaments
you actually get a warning for bad
sportsmanship or
you forfeit the match 9 ball is
considered a lucky game because you are
not
required to call the pocket at all
whereas eight ball or straight pool
normally require you to call the pocket
but there are some leagues and
tournaments that don't require to call
the shots
in the game of eight ball so eight ball
has a different set of rules depending
where you go
next stop seinfeld so what's your game
what do you like to play
thankful everyone's different you have
more people that have
sweat on their hands more than others
i've never had that problem my entire
career so i
never use powder but if you go into a
place that has
poor air conditioning or no air
conditioning at all and it's very humid
regardless of whether you have sweaty
palms or not that cue stick is going to
stick to your skin and it will be almost
impossible to slide it in a smooth
straight line he's exaggerating it here
i guess to be funny but
back in the days with the old pool halls
he used to have a
big chunk of chalk like this where you
would just rub your hand
on it and then you were ready to go
before you play
a break
a lot of people get confused they
believe that the cue ball must go
on the head spot which is a spot by
where you break from
they have a black line that's drawn
right by where the spot is
you can pretty much place the cue ball
anywhere behind that line it doesn't
necessarily have to be
right on the spot you'll notice that the
line that's drawn to
place the cue ball behind the line to
break is always
located by the second diamond every
table has diamonds in the side that's
where they normally draw the line by the
by the head of the table
the reason why you're seeing a lot of
jump shots is because they have no room
to stroke the cue stick their shooting
elbow is going up
and when that happens it forces the tip
down and when it forces the tip down
you actually end up hitting underneath
the cue ball and that's what jumps it
over sometimes you jump it off the table
sometimes you jump in the top of another
ball sometimes you jump it straight into
the pocket so that's what's going on
here
if the cue ball leaves the table after
jumping off the table then the incoming
player has either ball in hand anywhere
on the table
or behind the line depending on which
rules you're using
one thing that i think would have helped
them for the scene is what we call
shorty cues almost every bar you go to
has a short
cue it's usually half the size or even
less
so that way when you're shooting in
tight areas you have enough room to be
able to stroke the ball
yeah i've got a hunch fat man i can't
miss
it's definitely possible to shoot with a
baton kramer actually
did make those shots with the baton he
has to be very careful though which he
was
the only way that you can pocket those
balls is if you hit the exact center of
the cuba which he does for both shots
because if you were to hit it above or
below
the tip is so small it's just going to
slide right off or jump the cue ball
potentially if you hit it too low the
reason why you're only
able to strike the center of the cue
ball is because you can't chalk up a
baton
the tip of it is not made out of leather
the chalk won't hold him chalking was
kind of pointless
you know where it's going the last two
shots that he shot with the baton here
are not realistic there's no way
he shot those two shots with a baton
because when you have a baton it's so
short you need a lot of room to generate
speed by the time the tip of the cue
stick reaches a cue ball
you can't do that with a baton it's too
short you can't bring it all the way
back if you do it's gonna come off your
bridge hand
so if you notice a 10 ball bank shot was
shot with a lot of speed and the 5 ball
which was the last shot was shot with
even greater speed
it's impossible to hit the ball that
hard with a baton so that was definitely
shot by someone else with a regular q
stick
next stop boardwalk empire reputation
takes a lifetime to build
and only seconds to destroy
[Applause]
wreck them charlie i had the pleasure of
working
with michael stuhlbarg and vincent
piazza for this scene
this shot was extremely difficult to
teach to michael because he didn't
really have a pool background
and it took him one week before he
actually made it the first time
the shot that michael shoots in this
scene is considered a trick shot
a trick shot is a series of shots where
you
actually set up the balls yourself so
that way you increase the chances of
making multiple balls in one shot
when he strikes a cue ball and hits the
first ball to the left
that ball makes contact with the ball
that's
far in the front and it shoots you
straight to the corner pocket
and then the ball that just came off the
cue ball will bank one rail into the
corner pocket and then the cuba will
carry him
and strike the third ball and send them
to the same pocket it's a really neat
shot because all three balls go in the
same pocket i like to call the shot
follow the leader trick shots are
allowed in games
as long as you don't touch the balls so
trick shots don't really
exist in the game of pool it's something
that you actually set up for like a
party
i understand you're interested in the
liquor business who's interested in
making dough
piles of it
eight ball if you're playing eight ball
the only
requirement is to place the eight ball
at the center of the rack which is a
third row
you have to make sure that you put
pressure on the bottom five balls
the back of the rack so that way you
push them forward to make sure you give
yourself the best possible chance to
squeeze them together if you fail to do
that you're going to have a lot of gaps
and
it's going to lose a transfer of energy
because it's a delay
before one ball touches the other as
opposed to all the balls being frozen at
the same time
and exploding as soon as you hit him
i've had people come to me for years
saying you know
is it true that you rock solid strike
side of strikes i've only played in one
tournament maybe two
where that was actually a requirement
but for the most part it's actually
random
next stop mystic pizza it's your desire
[Music]
sorry partner his stance is correct
everything seems fine except
his bridge his bridge is completely off
a bridge
or a pool bridge is the hand placement
on the table that's what you use to
slide the cue stick off your hand
in order to strike the cue ball see the
fingers are supposed to always
stay together like this kind of like a
90 degree angle over here
right there his is like this separated
so there's no stability there so it
makes it tougher for him to hit the ball
exactly where he'd like to
when it comes to the open bridge is a
very simple way to form an open bridge
which is the one that's used from
about 70 60 70 of the shots and pool
what you do is you simply make a fist
you take the thumb bring it up as high
as possible
attach it to the knuckle and then you
simply spread the fingers like that
all four fingers should end up on the
table like this
that way you have stability throughout
the bridge
sorry partner the rules are actually the
same when you play what we call scotch
doubles now scotch doubles can be played
one of two ways
if i have a partner and my partner
shoots a shot and makes it
he or she can continue shooting until
they miss
the other way to play is alternate
scotch doubles
where we alternate shots so if i were to
let's say
pocket a ball now it's my teammate's
turn
to shoot if they pocket the ball then
now it's my turn to shoot
again as long as we keep pocketing balls
we keep our turn at the table we lose
our turn once one of us is missed
and that's actually the best way to do
it that's how most tournaments that are
scott troubles which there aren't a lot
but there are some out there
it gives everyone a chance to win
because if you have one player that's
better than the other three players
during the match
they're going to end up clearing the
table most of the time and it makes it
more fun that way
all right here's what we want
right down here honey going with the
orange if you are teaching or trying to
show
a beginner how to aim the best thing to
do is to tell them
or place a finger somewhere on the table
you would like them to hit the ball
don't be too hard on them if they don't
make the shot because this game is
extremely difficult you have to master
your fundamentals first
and your technique and then after you do
that and you have the ability to hit one
ball to the next
now you can start focusing a little more
on aiming aiming is actually
very hard in the game of pool and it
takes time to learn you're better off
making sure that you do your pre-shot
routine and you step directly into the
line of sight
when you're gonna aim in order to learn
how to aim properly and
strike the ball because if you fail to
do so you're just shooting blindly
you're never going to hit the exact spot
that you intended to
for the most part and therefore fail
[Music]
that's specifically why she missed her
shot she actually
failed to make contact with any ball
most of the time
when you do that you fail to make
contact with any ball the incoming
player actually gets to take the cue
ball
in their hand and place it anywhere on
the table take it easy honey
that's why we play boy girl do you even
think that
when i saw this part especially my wife
saw it she wanted to puke there's a
misconception that
women cannot play pool that is not
accurate at all they have some female
players that will pretty much
annihilate a lot of pool players so if
anyone says that a woman can't play it
that's not true
maybe back in the days the female
players never practiced their break
as much as a male player so they didn't
have the ability to break as hard
nowadays completely different story
[Music]
every shot that julia supposedly shot
they never actually physically show her
executing the shot she definitely did
not shoot
the any of these shots whatsoever and
this is proof right here
her form is terrible her head is crooked
it's tilted to the side her head is
supposed to be straight and right above
the cue stick and then her arm is like
all the way in like this
it should be out here the back arm you
could see
that it's actually the elbow is in when
you're actually shooting
your head is supposed to be in a
straight line with your shoulder your
elbow and your wrist
so that when you stroke the ball when
this all the way in like that or the
elbow or the wrist
it becomes very difficult for you to
deliver that cue stick in a smooth
straight line
she does an okay job i've seen far worse
she also does a no-look shot and that's
something that
people do just for fun or to kind of
show off in the tournament
you would never see a pool player look
away because there's too much money at
stake
professionals even if they're playing
for fun they always like to take their
practice very seriously
and one thing that i learned a long time
ago is when you practice
you have to actually practice as if you
were playing in a tournament because if
you do that it increases the chances of
you
getting into the mentality and reaching
what we call the zone in the game of
poor
but in this scene she didn't shoot that
shot as well the only
shot that she shot was the winning eight
ball
that was it and that you can actually
see her striking the cube one coming off
the cushion to make the eight ball
next stop bedazzle
oh doggy there is absolutely no way i'm
planning the earth anyone could ever
make that many balls in one shot you
have a better shot of hitting the sun
with a snowball
making that the most i ever made in a
trick shot was like 13 maybe 14 balls
there is a shot
that is possible to make but you have to
set it up and it takes about 30 minutes
to set up but as far as randomly hitting
a ball
it's impossible physically because once
the cue ball strikes an object ball
depending on how thick or thin it hits
it if it hits it dead
square the cue ball is going to lose all
of this energy it's going to transfer it
onto the object ball
and then that one is going to lose a
little energy once it hits other balls
and other balls
eventually everything is going to lose
speed so physically it is impossible to
actually make all the balls in one shot
so pull is definitely a game of physics
there's certain techniques that you can
use
if you have one ball here frozen to
another ball here
and they're lined up this way then what
happens is if you create a 90 degree
angle
just like this that means that if you
one ball hits the ball here
that ball is going to come off that ball
carry them off that one follow a perfect
90 degree angle
there is a little bit of geometry but
it's mostly feel
as the player continues to master the
game they just learn how to feel the
shots but these techniques are very
useful when it comes to learning
how to master certain aspects of the
game like shot making and also position
play
i've been playing pool for 41 years i've
never heard of a living human being
ever making all the balls in one shot
it's just unheard of
next stop pujol junkies i don't know
nick i think i got a banking there's
nothing else i can do
you can do it it's a two rail safety oh
i think you're right
a bank shot is when you shoot the cue
ball
into an object ball and the object ball
comes off a cushion and goes into a
pocket
a kick shot is when the cue ball
is struck and comes off the rail and
hits an object ball he gave him advice
and he says you can do this it's a two
rail safety
that meant that he needed to come off
the eight ball
and have the cue ball strike two rails
to hide it behind the nine ball
good shot so he needed to hit that ball
or that shot with
enough energy to get the eight pull to
stop in front of the nine but at the
same time have the cue ball go two rails
and stop behind
the nine on the opposite side it was
actually a very very good shot because
that shot is very tough
to execute the reason why he decided to
shoot a safety versus
an offensive shot is because the
offensive shot or the shot that he had
in the 8 ball
was a very low percentage shot because a
9 ball was actually preventing him
from banking it one rail into the corner
pocket
he could have tried to bank it in the
opposite pocket it didn't make any sense
to take that risk
in the game of pool we have different
types of equipment for different
situations that come up there's another
special cue that we use
called the jump cue it's usually about
40 inches long
or or shorter and it's almost weightless
it's about maybe four or five
six ounces and what they do is that it's
so light that when you elevated a 45
degree angle
and you strike down the cue ball it
actually forces a ball to jump over
another ball
that's what he did with this shot in
this scene he actually jumped the cue
ball over the nine ball
struck the eight ball and banged it one
rail which is unbelievable and it is
very possible because
i've seen that happen in major
tournaments if you use a special jump
cue
if you elevate the stick since it's so
light you're able to generate speed
much quicker if you shoot at a 45 degree
angle
hit it it will come off the slate and
the cloth
and jump over the object bar this one
when you scoop underneath
is illegal the reason why players
especially pros have jump cues is
because
whenever we use a jump cue we normally
aim the ball the same way we would
if the ball in front that we're trying
to jump over weren't there so it
increases the chances of us making the
shot as opposed to
having the cuba come off the cushion and
hit the ball and you hoping and praying
that it goes in
stop stop stop stop easy easy no no no
the part that i disagree with
was how they wound up with the
impossible shot if you take a look at
the clip again you'll notice that the
way that the balls were spread out the
cue ball was nowhere near the nine wife
that he struck the eight ball
and banked it across you know the table
to the side pocket there's no way the
balls
could ever roll together like that and
just nestle
against one another in in the in the
cushion like that
pool is definitely a game where you
constantly think
at least three shots ahead this scene is
so brilliant because
empoo we have players that pull what we
call moves
they trick you into believing that you
have a shot at winning when they devise
a way to actually win in the long run
what are you doing
i'm taking my shot i just paid five
thousand dollars
for your shot now it's my shot they
never discussed that
mars callahan would actually lose his
turn so that's why when he hit the shot
he'd
softly stop in front of the pocket which
is brilliant so the difference between
this shot
and the shot and bedazzled is the shot
of me dazzled
really was impossible there's no way you
can make all the balls in one shot
whereas this shot if he would have hit
it absolutely perfect
there's a very very small chance that he
might
make the ball for him to make that shot
he would have had to
hit it so perfectly that he gets lucky
to hit it exactly where he needs to
after coming one two cushions to make
contact with the nine bullets
very very very tough to make at the pro
level you can be ranked number one in
the world and you're not guaranteed to
make that shot
thanks for watching the clips with me i
had a lot of fun doing this
hope to see you next time